my mother was a philanthropist and now I
know you're asking let me give you the
answer yes a little bit like Melinda
Gates but with a lot less money she
carried out her philanthropy in our
community through a practice we call is
silica she supported the education of
scores of children and invited many to
live with us in our home in order to
access schools to mobilize resources for
building the local health clinic and the
maternity wing is named in memory of her
but most important she was indeed by the
community for her organizing skills
because she organized the community and
specifically women to find solutions to
anything that was needed he did all this
through is silica let me repeat that
word for you again is silica now it's
your turn
say it with me thank you
that word is in my language Kimura
goalie talking in western Kenya and now
you speak my language
so it's Erica is a pragmatic way of life
that embraces charity services and
philanthropy all together
the essence of a Sirica is to make it
clear to everybody that you're your
sister's keeper and yes you are your
brother's keeper mutual responsibility
for caring for one another
a literal simple English translation
would be equal generosity but the deep
philosophical meaning is caring together
for one another
so how does acidic really happen I grew
up in a farming community in western
Kenya I remember vividly the many times
that neighbors would go to an a neighbor
home a sick neighbor home and harvest
their crop for them I tagged along side
with my mother to community events into
women's events and had the conversation
about vaccinations to school building
the health center and really big things
renewing seeds for the next planting
season and of often the community would
come together to contribute money to
send a neighbor child to school not only
in the country but to universities
abroad as well and so we have a sergeant
the first sergeant in my country came
from that rural village
so what is reka did was to be inclusive
we as children would stand alongside the
adults and give our contributions of
money and our names were in scripted in
the community book just like every adult
and then I grew up went to universities
back at home and abroad obtained a few
degrees here and there became urbanized
and took up international jobs working
in development humanitarian work and
philanthropy and very soon Sarika began
to become small it dissipated and then
just disappeared in each place
I gained new vocabulary the vocabulary
of donors and recipients the vocabulary
of measuring impact return on investment
projects and programs communities such
as my childhood community became
referred to as poor vulnerable
populations those are the communities of
which literature speaks about as living
on a dollar at less than a dollar a day
and they become the targets of poverty
eradication programs and by the way they
are the targets of our first United
Nations sustainable development goal now
I'm really interested that we find
solutions to poverty and to the world's
other many big problems because they do
exist I however think that we could do a
better job and we could do a better job
by embracing silica so let me tell you
how first is reka a farms common
humanity for whatever that you do you
begin from the premises that you are
human together when you begin that you
are human together you see each other
differently you don't see a refugee
first and you don't see a woman first
and you don't see a person with a
disability first you'll see a human
being first that is the essence of
seeing a person first and when you do
that you value their ideas you value
their contribution small or big and you
value what they bring to the table that
is the essence of a Sirica I just want
to imagine what it would look like if
everyone in this room a medical doctor a
parent a lawyer a philanthropist
whatever you are if you embraced is reka
and made it your default what could we
achieve for each other
what could we achieve for Humanity what
could we achieve for peace issues
what could
we achieve for medical science let me
give you a couple of hints because I'm
going to ask you to accompany me in this
process of rebuilding and reclaiming is
Sirica with me first you have to have
faith that we are one humanity we have
one planet and we don't have two choices
about that so there is not going to be a
world that is high enough to separate
humanity so give up give up the walls
give them up please and we don't have a
planet buta bottom so that's really
important make that clear move on to the
next stage the second stage remember in
a Sarika every idea counts bridges have
big posters and they have nails every
idea counts small or big counts and pad
Sarika affirms that those who have more
really enjoy the privilege of giving
more it is the privilege to give more
and this is the time for women to give
more for women it is the time to give
more for women our parents when they
brought in other children to live with
us they didn't ask our permission they
made it clear that they had a
responsibility because they had gone to
school and they were they had an awning
and they made it clear that we should
understand it that their prosperity was
not our entitlement and I think that's
good wisdom from Miss Erica we could use
that wisdom today I think in every
culture in every place passing to the
next generation what we could do
together I have over the years
encountered silica in many places but
what gives me really the passion today
to impress a seeker is the work that I
do with women all over the world through
the Global Fund for women through
women's fans and through women's
movements globally if you work with
women you change every day because you
experience them living historico
together in what they do in the work
that I do we trust women leaders and
their ideas and we support them with
funding so that they can expand they can
grow and they can thrive within their
own communities
a woman in 1990 came to the Global Fund
with a big idea a woman from Mexico by
the name of lechero Gonzales and she
wanted to begin a fund that would
support a movement that would be rooted
in the communities in Mexico and she
received a grant of seven thousand five
hundred US dollars today 25 years later
samia's the name of the fund has raised
and spent within the community seventeen
point eight million dollars they have
they have impacted over 2 million people
and they work with a group of 600,000
women in Mexico during the recent
earthquake they were so well rooted that
they could quickly assess within the
community and with others what were the
short-term needs and what are the
long-term needs and I tell you long
after the lights are gone of Mexico
samia's will be there with the
communities with the women for a very
long time and that's what I'm talking
about when we are able to support their
ideas of communities that are rooted
within their own setting 30 years ago
there was very little funding that went
directly to women's hands in their
communities today we celebrate a hundred
and sixty-eight women's fans all over
the world a hundred of which are in this
country and they support they support
grassroots women's organizations
community organizations under the
leadership of girls and women and
together we have been able collectively
to give a billion dollars to women and
girls led organizations but the
challenge begins today the challenge
begins today because we see women
everywhere organizing as a silica
including women organizing us Sarika in
Ted because in Sirica is the Evergreen
wisdom that lives in communities you
find it in indigenous communities in
rural communities and what it really in
grains in people is that ability to
trust and to move the agenda ahead so
three things that I have lunch that I
want to share with you through my work
one if you want to solve the world's
biggest problems invest in women and gas
not only do they expand the investments
but they care for everyone in the
community not only their needs but the
needs of the children the needs of the
rest of the community the needs of the
elderly and most important they protect
themselves which is really important and
they protect their communities women who
know how to protect themselves know what
it means to make a difference and the
second reason that I'm asking you to
invest in women and girls is because
this is the smartest thing you could
ever do at this particular time and if
we are going to have over 350 trillion
dollars by 2030 those dollars who need
to be in the hands of women and so I
grew up with a Sirica my mother was the
Sirica she was not a project or a
program and now I passed that to you
that you would be able to share this
with your families with your friends and
with your community and embrace a Sirica
as a way of living as a pragmatic way of
living thank you
[Applause]
[Music]